I'm here with Jason RV and Porsche RIA
how surprised were you then with the
success of my Morphin Power Rangers to
begin with really surprised have you
seen the thing it's terrible what's that
right oh my god have you don't sell
anything
well it ain't Hamlet that's for sure
you know I mean here's the thing with um
you get any acting gig night mad at a
time 10 you know at nine out of ten
times it's gonna be shocked okay
and so we filmed it we're like this
might be pretty schlocky we actually saw
them sometimes oh sure it's going to be
schlock but when we saw the final
schlock we said wow holy schlock this
might actually sell I mean they can sell
this schlock so I can we talk talk talk
and you came back then because it
evolved obviously it was absolutely huge
at the beginning but then it became sort
of a retro thing for people as they grew
up but you came back I think to seven
different iterations as bulk and skull
how did it change across that time for
you
well poly came back more than I did I
mean it so that 20 year gap between the
first season and the final season you
did that was huge
yes yeah I mean I mean we were on the
show for more than half of that time I
mean because while many of you grew up
and moved on to middle school and in
high school and then jobs then children
and then horrific boredom
we were perpetually on the show I mean
I've done 11 seasons on Power Rangers
Jason's done seven and then I doing new
for customs you know so I mean sure look
heroes come and go but idiots are
forever now that was weird is coming
back to it after 20 years and now you're
like we're doing the same character oh
wait it's not the same person because
now they're 20 years older
that was weird was that not that's sure
that's true I mean I I still tried to
find the the route idiot in it oh yeah
absolutely
so talking about coming back then
they're making a new movie lines get
you're making it 2016 a new massive
Power Rangers movie how likely are we to
see you guys involved it'll ah not very
likely unlikely because if you think
about the sheer vast number of former
cast members on the show they would need
a room about this size is young everyone
at this con used to be on record yes
every Thursday up there's the original
brothers originally others legends never
7cm Gregory oh good god yeah come there
is Boston st. John Ranger oh there's
only one Austin burrito say good guy
well no though I'm sure people to want
to see you to back over a lot of people
I was on a message board yesterday and
people are all talking about one in
Balkans go back is there any chance we
would see you back at all I mean it
here's the deal okay when you reboot you
got to do two things you need a
completely reinvention which means you
need new actors to do your new
interpretation of those roles yeah but
you need to pay homage for the old food
and we are old things my friend so it
might happen there is a snowball's
chance in hell that we'll be back if
you're in control of this movie then
where would you go with it would you
completely reboot it oh yeah for sure oh
yeah totally
a lot more fire yeah yeah lot more fire
more fire more Michael Bay style most
explosions yeah sure explosions but what
we would do is we make all the vehicles
real and all the actual actors CGI Daisy
dude we thought about more Daisy the
oxygen so the Ranger suit should come
right all even the boys she came out
just boy tears boy [ __ ] there and
Balkans girl would wear clothes cuz that
would sell that would sell girl ain't
disagree on that one this is an x-rated
cinema good guy final question then all
the cars came and went as you went along
but you two were there together how was
it having each other by each other side
for the whole experience you know
there's a difference between the man
that's recruited into the war the final
year seeing one battle maybe then the
men that were there when the first shots
were fired
there's a certain understanding and a
certain need that another man has thank
you so much for time I look forward to
seeing you in the new Power Rangers
maybe then
thanks man look forward to it
you